I saw him staying over in the mosque and
I told him that he had to leave right
and that was the first incident another
incident what why would he stay over I
think he was here probably from fajar
from early morning prior he stayed
behind while everybody had gone because
some people like to stay and wait and
pray just before the sunrise right and
because you get a lot of blessing for
doing that so they would stay and pray
and then after that they would go home
and go to school or work or whatever
they're going to go so I think he was
one of them that stayed behind but he
stayed after because I normally come
here between 10:00 and 11:00 and
hovering in the know in the morning in
the morning and then when I came I heard
somebody coming
you know flush and eat I did so when I
went to look it was him and he's got on
his trainers and I was very annoyed
about it because you can't come from the
toilet and walking on the mats we are we
going to do with and then from there
we're going to Compton was to pray so I
was very very annoyed with him he said
don't treat him as a child I said you
were a child if he wasn't a child you
know you Nutter
would not behave like that because you
should know better you know and that was
my last confronted confrontation with
him and that's the last point the iewk
remember him doing here
that was the last point that I spoke to
him you know after that if you come and
pray I don't know because I'm not
noticing because normally when I come in
everybody's in the front row I greet
them and I start indifferent myself so
if he's behind I don't know after I
finished praying I go back to my office
downstairs what do you do as an
organization to stop radicalization to
stop the signs that you might spot here
among young people right well we we do
talk to them about it and I put a notice
up on my door that do it there is a
notice there right where I'm telling
people that I I don't want anyone to be
staying in the mosque after we have
prayed because I don't know what
conversation they'll be having so I
don't want to entertain them and I said
no one to come to politics likewise but
is it it's a sign on a door enough not
no it's not enough but it
no suspicion brothers ask me why you put
it up
I said I'm putting it up because I don't
want anyone to stay here too you know to
be doing anything concerning terrorism
or anything like that
I don't want anything to be in salah
masjid are you doing enough to prevent
atrocities because this man went on to
commit an atrocity yeah I appreciate
that you had no way of telling that no
but deep do you feel that you do enough
to highlight people that you believe may
be having those conversations I don't
think you can never do enough you have
to keep trying because sometimes when
you talk to people you just like
accomplished one hears and they go to
the other so you know a good buzz and so
on we're encouraging our Imams to keep
talking about it right so that our
youths don't take up that that line do
you share things can create a mansion a
place well at one time I used to be on
the police forum when they were having
meetings and so on we used to go but
that stuff for a long while but I have
probably surfaces coming and we sit and
talk up - couple days ago we was talking
- no twice this week we were talking
with the police you know and if anything
like that is going on and I realized it
up the first one to report them we know
yeah that there are other young men who
come from this part of South Manchester
who come and prayed at this building
yeah Raymond Mattoon burr is one of them
right he has gone off to fight for is in
Syria yeah what can you tell us about
him and why why that happened
you know that was really a surprise to
me when I heard that he had gone to
Syria there was one guy used to come in
here an Afghan sky and said he's
teaching Koran say actually can he teach
Quran two new converts so I told him yes
so he used to stop there about three or
four of them right and they used to be
reading the Quran so we leave them to do
that because I thought that's what
they're doing but later on I got to find
out he was arrested and I understand
that the other black ladder when
- Cecilia and I believe he got killed
there you know so all we can do is try
not to have gatherings because we're not
we don't know what exactly what they're
doing in the gathering scene we are not
sitting with them so that I'm stopping
I'm not allowing them to have any
gathering anymore
you know if you're coming I want to read
Quran while we are here you can read
while you're here but when we are going
you have to go so we no longer live in
the building yeah yeah and Raphael hasti
did he have connections here till it it
should I don't know the names of them
okay yeah I don't show the pictures yeah
you confirm the answer yeah so that it's
Salman Abady who was the one on Monday
night idea Raphael Hosty I don't know
him okay we believe he was a recruiter
who came from this part of Manchester
who write who encouraged Salman to you
know get involved with is yeah and then
the other phases were here Steven gray
convert I'm not certain of this lad yeah
I said there was lots Raymond blue
timber
yeah is it I think that that is a black
lad I think yes yeah but there should be
an afghan-led and Ronald fiddler he died
in Syria he I knowed very well you know
Ronald Harry I know him a long time you
know I didn't expect he would do that as
well because he was in Guantanamo Bay
yeah and then he came out back to
Manchester and then off to Syria yeah I
know that he because I know him from
back in the 70s it not 80s and he was
living in Wally range because his sister
was only living on the corner here and
he went to Sudan to study yeah and then
he said he going to go to Pakistan to
study so when he went to Pakistan to
study that's where he he got picked up
first right you know that's the only way
I could tell you about him but I didn't
know that he had anything to do with
terrorism until I later learned that he
got some money from the government
yeah and I thought probably you got that
amount of money why would you not settle
down and you know with your family and
so and then next minute I get here he's
dead
you